Let's say you meet a new classmate and you agree at a local coffee shop to
study. You've met this person at the coffee shop three different occasions, and
on each occasion the person's late. After the third time the person comes late
you think to yourself that this person is just lazy. Or maybe they're selfish
because whatever they're doing must be so much more important than meeting you
on time. This is an example of dispositional attribution, because you're
explaining the person's behavior from an internal cause, that is that they're
lazy. So dispositional attributions are when we explain other people's behavior
as being due to something from within the individual, such as a person's
personality, talent, attitude, or motivation. So let's take this example again
of a person being repeatedly late to a study session. Perhaps you think the
reason why the person's late is because they've gotten caught up with something
at work and couldn't leave on time. Or perhaps because there was traffic or the
person was home helping their sick mother. If you were to use one of these
reasons for explaining the individual's tardiness, then you would be using
situational attribution. A situational attribution, is when we think that
something outside of a person, such as the nature of a situation or
circumstance is the cause of the behavior.